>> I DISCOURAGE ANY DISCUSSION
OF IMPEACHMENT.
ON THE POLITICAL SIDE, I THINK
IT'S A GIFT TO THE REPUBLICANS
TO TALK ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
>> THE LAST THING THIS COUNTRY
NEEDS IS IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS
THAT MOVE FORWARD AS A MATTER OF
COURSE BECAUSE WE DON'T LIKE THE
PRESIDENT.
>> YOU CAN'T JUMP THE GUN AND
DETERMINE THAT SOMEBODY SHOULD
BE IMPEACHED WHEN YOU'RE GOING
TO BE VOTING ON THE IMPEACHMENT
ISSUE.
IT IS TOO EARLY TO TALK ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT.
>> THEY'RE ALL LYING.
THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BASE
WANTS THE PRESIDENT IMPEACHED.
JOHN NICHOLS WRITES THIS SORT OF
PIECE ASKING WHY ARE SO MANY
DEMOCRATS AFRAID OF IMPEACHMENT?
JOHN NICHOLS JOINS US TONIGHT.
JOHN, I DON'T THINK WITH YOU ON
MUCH.
NORMALLY I'D BE HERE ARGUING
WITH YOU, BUT I'LL GIVE YOU A
SINCERE COMPLIMENT, YOUR PIECE
WAS HONEST.
THIS IS THE PRESCRIBED REMEDY
FOR A PRESIDENT THAT'S BELIEVED
TO GONE OFF THE RAILS.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
YOU DO.
DEMOCRATS SUPPORT IT.
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY'RE NOT
WILLING TO ADMIT IT?
>> I THINK THEY'RE PLAYING A
POLITICAL GAME.
YOU ASSUME THEY WOULD IMPEACH IF
THEY GOT POWER.
I'M NOT SURE OF THAT.
>> HUH.
>> I THINK THAT THERE IS A
TEPIDNESS ABOUT USING
IMPEACHMENT AS A LIVE INSTRUMENT
OF THE CONSTITUTION, HOLDING A
PRESIDENT WHO HAS, AS YOU
SUGGEST, GONE OFF THE RAILS, WHO
I WOULD SUGGEST ABUSES THE
OFFICE TO ACCOUNT.
BUT CLEARLY AT THIS POINT
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS PRESSURE ON
MEMBERS OF THE PARTY, AND ON
FOLKS TO NOT TALK ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT.
MY SENSE IS THAT IT'S
PROBLEMATIC.
IF YOU ARE SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HAS ABUSED HIS OFFICE, IF YOU
ARE SUGGESTING THAT HE'S DOING
THINGS THAT ARE CLEARLY
IMPEACHABLE, BUT THEN YOU SAY,
WELL, BUT LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT, THAT CREATES AN
UNREALITY TO THE DISCOURSE, AND
FRANKLY IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE.
I THINK THAT, A, A DISCUSSION OF
IMPEACHMENT IS HEALTHY.
I THINK IT'S NECESSARY.
BUT B, IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT
I THINK POLITICIANS OF BOTH
PARTIES TEND TO FEAR TOO MUCH.
>> WHAT I LIKE ABOUT IT --
AGAIN, I'M NOT FOR IT, BUT IT'S
ABOVEBOARD.
IT TAKES PLACE IN PUBLIC.
PEOPLE CAN MAKE THEIR PUBLIC
ARGUMENTS.
INSTEAD THEY'RE SUBVERTING
ENTIRE FEDERAL AGENCIES, AND
LIBERALS SHOULD BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS.
IF YOU HAVE A CASE, BE A MAN
ABOUT IT, SAY WHAT IT IS, VOTERS
CAN ASSESS IT.
THAT'S WHY THE FOUNDERS PUT
ITING IN THE DOCUMENTS.
WHY WOULD THEY PRETEND IT'S OFF
THE TABLE?
IT SEEMS SO FELINE AND
DISHONEST.
>> AGAIN, I'M NOT SURE THEY'RE
PRETENDING, TUCKER.
WE'LL SEE IF DEMOCRATS GET
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE WHETHER
THEY WOULD MOVE ON IT.
BACK IN THE GEORGE W. BUSH
PRESIDENCY THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT AGITATION AT THE
GRASSROOTS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, AND FRANKLY BEYOND IT,
AMONG A LOT OF FOLKS, FOR
IMPEACHMENT OF PRESIDENT BUSH.
>> I REMEMBER.
>> I KNOW YOU DO, BECAUSE YOU
FOLLOWED IT.
NANCY PELOSI CAME TO POWER IN
2007, AND ONE OF HER FIRST
SIGNALS WAS ABLE THE
SIGNALS WAS OBLE THE
SIGNALS WAS OFFE THE
SIGNALS WAS OFF TTHE
SIGNALS WAS OFF THEE
SIGNALS WAS OFF THE TABLE.
THIS IS A COMPLEXITY ON THIS
ISSUE.
WHERE IT GOES BACK TO, YOU AND I
BOTH KNOW, IS THE CLINTON
IMPEACHMENT, AND THERE'S A SENSE
THAT THE CLINTON IMPEACHMENT LED
TO POLITICAL REPERCUSSIONS FOR
REPUBLICANS.
IN FACT, IF YOU LOOK AT IT IT,
THE REPERCUSSIONS ARE NOT AS
MUCH AS PEOPLE ASSUME.
THE NIXON IMPEACHMENT, NOT
BROUGHT TO FRUITION, BUT A
SERIOUS MOMENT, THERE WEREN'T
POLITICAL REPERCUSSIONS FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN THAT.
I DO THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF
POLITICIANS ON BOTH SIDES,
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS, WHO
AVOID ACCOUNTABILITY MOMENTS --
AND FRANKLY AVOID OPENING UP THE
DISCUSSIONS WHEN THEY SHOULD BE
DOING SO.
>> RIGHT, EXACTLY.
THEY'RE AVOIDING ACCOUNTABILITY.
I HAVE TO SAY -- AGAIN, I DON'T
THINK I AGREE WITH YOU ON
ANYTHING, INCLUDING WHAT TO
ORDER THE DINNER, BUT I
APPRECIATE THE HONESTY OF THE
ACTUAL LEFT, YOUR
ACTUAL LEFT YYOUR
ACTUAL LEFT YOUUR
ACTUAL LEFT YOURR
ACTUAL LEFT YOUR PARTY TO